[Música]
con solo 22 años maxam mini es el rostro
de las protestas masivas que han
sacudido a Irán tres días antes de su
muerte amín una joven kurda fue detenida
en Teherán por llevar ropa inapropiada o
como lo consideró la policía de la moral
que la detuvo porque su hillab no le
cubría el pelo
lo que sucedió después no está claro
según las autoridades amín y murió en el
hospital después de que su frágil salud
las llevara a caer en coma incluso
llegaron a mostrar Este vídeo en el que
se ve a la joven desplomarse
también difundieron imágenes de su
supuesto traslado al hospital donde
dicen que murió
al parecer tenía un historial de
enfermedades que se indican el informe
fue operada del cerebro a los 5 años
miles de personas salieron a las calles
de todo el país exigiendo
responsabilidades argumentando que
estaba Claro que fue golpeada hasta la
muerte sobre todo porque la policía de
la moral ha sido acusada de abusos
contra los Derechos Humanos al día
siguiente miles de personas asistieron a
su funeral en su ciudad natal de saqués
en el kurdistán y es aquí donde el
movimiento se intensificó con un gesto
muy arriesgado Y es que en los días
siguientes se hizo viral mujeres iraníes
se quitaron el jillado en la calle
incluso lo quemaron a pesar de que el
gobierno cortó la conexión a internet en
el país los hechos se siguieron
conociendo tanto estudiantes como
académicos se involucraron en el
movimiento y Los hombres también se
unieron para denunciar la supresión de
las mujeres
Mira las calles las personas que
protestan junto las mujeres son hombres
al lado de cada mujer hay un hombre que
se defiende
desde la indignación inicial no ha
pasado un día sin una manifestación en
Irán y el movimiento se ha extendido
hasta ciudades y regiones el gobierno
iraní reprimió a las multitudes con
fuerza mientras aumentaba el número de
heridos de tensiones e incluso muertes
pero nada detuvo el desafío de las
mujeres iraníes y otra ola de
resistencia se hizo viral esta vez
cortándose el pelo el 3 de octubre el
líder supremo del país habló por segunda
vez desde que comenzaron las protestas
pero desestimó las manifestaciones
digo claramente que estos disturbios y
la inseguridad han sido diseñados por
Estados Unidos y el falso
régimensionista ocupante de Israel así
como por sus agentes a sueldo con la
ayuda de algunos iraníes traidores en el
extranjero
el pasado domingo el canal Estatal de
noticias fue hackeado por activistas
digitales que apoyan protestas pidiendo
la salida déjame nade del poder